the fear is is marijuana the Trojan
horse because there are people in this
country are fighting for the legalized
of a legalization of decriminalization
of all drugs the government has as much
of a right to control what I as an adult
put into my body as it does what I put
into my mind it's none of their business
[Music]
texan regular cannabis is in this
statewide initiative that would allow
for adults 21 years of age and older to
possess up to an ounce and cultivate 25
square feet it will also allow for
cities and counties to decide how an if
they would like to tax the commercial
sales and commercial cultivation this is
a public policy nightmare and the folks
who drafted and crafted this initiative
really did it a little half-baked if you
will and tons of flaws problems
economically problems in the workplace
problems on the road are we as a society
ready and willing to accept another
intoxicant and then deal with all the
social consequences that comes along
with that first of all we have to look
at another intoxicant in our roadways if
you use marijuana you can use it right
before getting into a vehicle and
driving you can use you can stop you can
use marijuana you know in the middle of
a trip and then get back in the car law
enforcement professionals will tell you
that they don't have a they don't really
have a scale not like blood alcohol
level you can judge how impaired you are
one of the challenges is that it's in it
puts California in direct conflict with
federal law paying a tax to your city to
your local government to your state
you're putting yourself you know on
basically a listing to the federal
government yeah we're marijuana dealers
one of the other challenges is it puts
California and direct conflict with the
federal drug free workplace act in Eddie
city and a county and a government
agency School District University
government contractor anybody who gets
federal funding of a hundred thousand
dollars or more has to comply with a
drug-free workplace at how do you deal
with that how do you comply with that
when your employees very likely are
going to test positive
I think everybody kind of understands
that our current drug policy has failed
and by root taxing and regulating
cannabis will make for safer communities
and allow for the state to have a chance
to get out of its budget deficit big
time drug dealers they're making
hundreds of millions billions of dollars
every year tax free by the way right now
this drug violence going on down in
Mexico it's awful and I can tell you one
thing for certain the drug cartels do
not want you to vote YES on the tax
cannabis initiative we in the state of
California as taxpayers literally could
save hundreds of millions of dollars per
year if not a billion dollars a year
that now we actually spend in a futile
effort to try to eradicate marijuana as
well as to incarcerate prosecute and
incarcerate nonviolent marijuana
offenders and of course you can tell how
successful we are in Marin eradication
of marijuana because it's still the
largest cash crop in the state of
California California is a
decriminalized state and its medical
marijuana state and we're still resting
you know seventy five thousand people a
year that's outrageous it's a waste of
resources people are really asking
questions about why are we wasting
taxpayers money trying to arrest
prosecute and imprison marijuana
offenders when we could be reaped you
tax benefits from a legally regulated
market I don't know if really they're
going to see the economic boon out of it
because of the the race to the bottom as
far as taxation the regulation and cost
a regulation that they're going to have
to incur and will they be getting enough
money from their taxation in order to
fund that additional regulation you know
the the fact that people can grow at
home why would you go to a store the
entire hemp industry could be
revitalized goes back thousands of years
to the degree that in ancient Greek the
word canvas and cannabis were synonymous
they were the same word and we have
simply forted that entire really
important industrial purpose that it's a
perfect storm for proponents because the
state is in a fiscal crisis in the
cities and counties
in a fiscal crisis but the challenge is
we have to decide as a society just
because we can raise revenue from it
does that make it right if Americans
have a right to drink alcohol smoke
cigarettes and have guns then they have
a right to smoke a joint it's as simple
as that at one point as a society we're
going to come morally bankrupt this
could be that line people that are
supporting the status quo are on the
wrong side of history two years after we
change away from this failed and
hopeless policy everybody will join arms
look back astonished aghast that we
could have perpetuated such a failed
system for so long are you high right
now absolutely none